I wrote you every day for a year
[Music]
the idea was this place had some magic
to it the Ducks in the lake at the size
and scope of the place reflected how
much he loves but new einzige no birds
and so while they said no bird it can't
be done I walked out of there with my
line producer and my line producer said
I like the birds they send me to it what
we did unbeknownst to the one we had a
guy that was in parks and services
department and and she said I have a
wing so we did is we bought 80 or 90
hatchlings of these geese we kept him in
a semi trailer every day and he would
March them out to the lake and feed them
and then March them back to the trailer
and after a few months of this during
pre-production they became bigger Birds
by the time we got there on the day the
studio came down they were mad that
we're doing the birds for this better
work the parks and service guy marched
him out there like the Pied Piper they
did their thing and he marched them
right back like the greatest trained
animals you've ever seen in their life
the rain scene is a poster and the scene
that a lot of people remember there's
been a bright beautiful sunny day and
didn't feel right so we shut it down and
that's it and try to find me a cloudy
day it'll be better if there get caught
in a thunderstorm there's rain towers
that have big pink lers at the top and
you localize the rate with the camera
where you want us you put your
unfortunate standards in the spot and
then you adjust the sprinklers until it
looks like it's raining lateral thinking
that's still making in a nutshell he
gets to something laterally and get what
you want another way Rachel and Ryan
were a revelation
they had beneath the surface chemistry
initially they didn't get along there
was something built up between these two
kids and it has nothing to do with
directing this scene was like he's mad
at her she's mad at him he says he wrote
her every day and that's the key though
I'm allowed to the door and when that
door got unlocked I didn't need to
direct enough who sparks the flyer they
wound up together for many years after
the movie
they weren't together before that gift
but they were together after that kiss
[Music]
you